les martinets cenon réseau qui s'y
déplacent moins constamment ne voit
jamais marché sur une branche au sol
sous - feignies est donc toujours en
mouvement dans une journée on est celle
qui est capable de faire plusieurs
cantons et firme ait ouvre donc c'est
sûr que s'ils arrivent à un endroit où
normalement ils vont se reposer pour
passer la nuit
qui c'est un droit de l'homme n'existe
plus le choix de se trouver un autre
endroit pour commencer l'année il compte
tenu qu'ils étaient capables de se
déplacer lors beaucoup il n'y a pas de
trouver pour mam un drôle de retour dans
les villes et villages ou aux environs
de rouler normalement
il peut aller comme ça au rayon d'action
une fois qu'ils découvrent que ça
chemine et voilà il peut aller à 100 km
oui je pense qu'il est capable la face
surtout qu'elle est licite de repos le
groupe h la nuit ce qu'on appelle aussi
des dortoirs
c'est surtout utilisé en période de
migration jeux sont peu avant la période
des négociations donc sont encore une
période où son père samain et éviterez
deviennent donc ils sont en train de se
déplacer donc peu coincé peut-être que
les oiseaux qui était énormément avec
mega brands un violent retour qui aura
ces gens jouent à ce budget bon ça
représentait 50 70 la main mais pour
martin et ne pensez pas
et ce challenge ça fait loin
mont-laurier et en ontario peut-être en
ontario mais on ne sut aussi dans une
petite ville pas très loin de champville
de 5,6 de ma chambre je pense 2 juin
quelques jours il y avait une centaine
de morts on connaissait pas c'est un
nouveau dortoir ou si c'est un nouvel
endroit qui martelaient commencé en
tunisie
donc on pense que c'est un exemple
d'oiseaux qui sont pas déplacés en
périphérie d'où il était normal